can we actually take a attention to an
attention on attention and attention how
old is the universe can you can you dig
in onto this number how do we know
currently with those i guess you said
five four or five uh
significant digits so we can come about
it from two different ways one uh
basically they rely on the most
important number in cosmology which is
called the hubble constant the hubble
constant is this weird number that has
the following units it has the units of
kilometers per second per megaparsec so
it's a speed per distance which means
you multiply it by distance and you get
a speed and what is the speed you're
measuring well you're measuring the
speed of a distant galaxy at many
megaparsecs away so a galaxy at one
megaparsec this isn't actually strictly
true because of local gravitational
effects uh but if you go out say one
megaparsec i would say that that galaxy
is moving 72 kilometers per second away
from you and every galaxy except for the
local very most local group surrounding
us maybe a half a dozen galaxies out of
50 to sorry sorry out of uh
500 billion galaxies to perhaps a
trillion galaxies so 12 out of that
number
are moving towards us the rest are
moving away from us
so that number if you invert it
if you say well when did those things
last touch each other all those galaxies
now they're really far apart we know how
fast they're moving away it's a very
simple algebra problem to solve when
were they touching that's where you get
that number from so there's the local 12
and then the rest ignore the 12 yeah and
then ignore the 12 and then look at the
others and yeah the then solve the
algebra problem
uh how does the
and stuff in the beginning the mystery
of that beginning epic changed this
calculation of very little because
actually we understand um how there's
some other ingredients that go into it
namely how much dark energy there is in
the universe how much dark matter there
is in the universe how much radiation
light neutrinos etc
and how much ordinary matter like we're
made up of neutrons protons croutons
okay so let me
morons
you